okay there are two things missing from
this show at the moment a bottle of beer
for me to drink and someone to drink it
with but I have managed to organize one
of those things need a clot joins us
you're from the magazine hop from hilden
which translates as the hop heroes what
makes them such heroes over there these
craft beer guys something new here but
elsewhere in the world they've been
around for quite some time haven't they
that's true it took quite a while for
Germany to hop onto the craft beer wagon
and I guess there are several reasons
for that one us German be it has always
been quite ok so there was no burning
need to look for any better different
beers and the second thing is if you
look at you and a German supermarket
shelf you might get the impression that
we've got him huge variety of fiercely
there are thousands of them as I said
book true true but if you look closely
you will see that it's only many beer
brands that you find there but not many
beer stars there's hella Spitzer fights
and that's pretty much it and there's a
hundred of twenty beer styles out there
and we're not brewing them ok so the
craft is really are very crafty and that
they go a heap further than your regular
beers do is that what you're saying
that's what yeah exactly craft beer
brewers they think beer a step further
they are looking for old recipes they
are looking for uncommon beers to brew
in Germany they can do so because they
they're producing smaller scales so they
can experiment they can just try if a
sour beer works in Germany or not and
they come at a good time because people
are drinking less beer yes they are if
you ask brewers it's it's mainly women
that stopped drinking beer or that that
are not drinking as much beer SS in the
early days and I guess that's because
they get an other beverages to choose
from but it's not enough to offer women
and beer with Johannes Pierre or some
sort of berries or make a pink no no I
don't think that's enough you have to
think beer dear friend and look for
different tastes maybe women like and a
really hoppy IPA that taste like peaches
or something like that what's an IPA for
people who don't know it's called an
India Pale Ale it's an old English beer
style and it's very popular amongst
craft brewers because it's very happy
and everyone can choose from his own
hops and
make it very very strong pro fight to
the BN of these beers any healthier um
well if it comes to alcohol definitely
not they might be a bit healthier
because you're drinking less of it maybe
okay so it's more about enjoying the
beer or not getting carried away with it
yeah okay Nina will get back to you in a
moment